These welcome to the show. No Gallagher
[inaudible]. So, uh, so D do you do your, remember the, the election nights,
do you have the night it happen happened Brexit, Brexit.
Uh, I was in the studio the day of the vote and, uh,
there was a vote in station across the road from the studio,
and I thought I can't be bothered going to vote because who'd vote to leave.
Right. So, uh,
we were all told that we would stay by landslide. So we just carried on working,
kind of went home. And, uh,
I went to bed at about 11 and everyone said we were going to stay.
And that was it. And it's great.
And I woke up the next morning and the world had changed. And, uh,
we've been in a mess ever since.
You come from a very different background than, than the Johnson's. Yes. Uh,
you came. Yeah, well, most people did, but
did you, it's not her fault. That's not hurtful, but do you have,
I mean, having, growing up in a very poor environment,
do you have an understanding of why it happened.
At the time when the referendum was called?
I was asked about it and I said that shouldn't be a referendum because I don't
think that knife at 99% of the people were qualified enough to understand
what was going on and watching the debates ever since in the announces of
parliament, not even the people who were qualified or qualified.
[Inaudible].
Now we are voted to leave by hook or by crook,
we have to leave because if we don't, we're not a democracy.
And if we're not a democracy,
we cannot pontificate to the rest of the world about democracy. So we have to,
we have to leave now and make and make the best of it. But I kind of,
I think I hope in my heart of hearts one day we'll we'll go.
Did, did, did, did, did the question split your family as well?
You never got that one.
Well, my family was very split on other things, uh, uh,
not, well, my, my immediate family I've got young children,
me and me and my wife. Uh, no, we were, we were,
we w I, I would have voted. I mean, if it was a vote again tomorrow,
I'd vote to stay.
Let me just ask you a question that I could,
given that there was the margin was quite slim and it's been three and a half
years, right? Think of all the 16, three, you know,
the young people who could vote. No.
And think of the majority that has probably gone to
happy hunting grounds.
So actually there's maybe a majority in this country to stay in,
but you think that still, we have to observe, like, I.
Hate, I hate this term, the people's vote vote,
and for better, or for worse, the people have spoken. Yeah.
They can't have referendums legal referendums with
illegal vote. And then so, but actually we don't like while you voted,
so we're going to have to have another one. It's not fair. It's not fair. Yeah.
Um, so I take it. You don't, you don't want to leave the EU if, if,
if it was up to you, but you, you did 10 years ago, you left the Oasis.
How did you, you, you, and it is 10 years ago this fall. And do you,
it was very abruptly. And, um, uh,
it was some said it was brave South side. It was stupid.
How what's, what's your thoughts when you, when you think back on that moment.
I didn't think it was brave or stupid.
It was just inevitable that it was gonna happen. And, uh, you know,
you got to a certain point in your life, or as I've,
I was 42 at the time.
And still really, you know, if, if,
if you're in a job that makes,
that's making you unhappy at that stage in your life, you just got to think,
well, you know, there's no point, I mean, surely the pursuit of happiness is,
is everybody's right. You know what I mean? And, um,
the way that it's been rewritten by the other fella is like, you know,
you mean any deals? Oh yeah.
All I did was leave abound.
That's all I did. You know, I didn't kill anybody yet.
Um, uh, you know, to some people it's the end of the world, you know,
it's the end that people can't will not still accept it. I got asked about,
well, that's fantastic. That's great. You know, and I, I,
they've got the music and they've got the memories if they ever came to see us.
But it w it was, I mean, it, it was an emotional thing.
It wasn't thought through. Was it?
Well, it was thought through very briefly in the back of a car
outside, look, sitting outside a festival that we were headlining.
It was about 70,000 people there. And, um,
there was a huge fight in the dressing room.
And I sat in the back of the car and I calmed down on my security guard,
said, are we staying or going? And I made,
I I've been on the verge of leaving a couple of times before.
And I just thought, tonight's the night,
the worst thing was leaving the people in the gig. I that's, I've never,
I'd never pulled a gig on purpose in my life, but, um, it was meant to be,
you know, and I've got no regrets at all.
So when from there,
when was the next time you heard from your brother? Uh,
did he try to call him desperate? Was I got.
A legal letter from his lawyers that he kindly managed to
give it to the daily minute of the day before he sent it to me.
So it was on the front page of the newspapers. And if you can believe this,
he was going to Sue me for libel,
for ruining his character.
For me, his characters somewhat.
Like slammed the wave. I don't know what the legal.
Term, you know. So who, who,
who would you prefer if you had to choose, who,
who would you prefer to have as your brother today? Uh, Liam or bar restaurant.
[inaudible].
Say Boris is more entertaining.
His use of the English language is far superior Liam's by looking at it.
So I don't know. I probably wouldn't get on with these kids wise.
I think Liam is magnificent. She's got magnificent.
[inaudible].
We were watching, uh, the, the panel show on sky, me and my wife recently.
And we both said she's looking great.
Yeah. Well, what's the thing with Boris here.
What about an interesting haircut? It's like, it's not sleep. That is fine.
I don't think it's he, you can't shape it or anything? No.
It's not. As, it's not as, uh, thick.
It's a different texture. Tell me, do you, w w when,
when you look back at those years before the breakup with
Oasis,
do you think about things you didn't appreciate enough?
I don't regret a single day being in that bond, because I always liked the work.
I often used to feel sorry for the other guys in the band,
because I was the sole writer and I always have to work to keep me
grounded, but it actually kept me sane in a way, you know, because I was,
I was busy work and, you know, directing it and all that,
but I don't regret anything. I don't, I don't,
there's some things that I said about other people that I wish I hadn't said.
And there's some things that I did that I wish I did,
but if I could go back and live it all again, I'd do it in a heartbeat.
From the outside.
It looks like you are a cool as a
cucumber compared to your brother. And, uh,
I wonder today you have, you have three kids.
Actually annoys him more than you could imagine. In fact that.
Some people think that, or the fact that you are that because,
yeah, because that can be.
When you're arguing with someone when you're and the other person is just like,
whatever. I mean, it's infuriating, of course, which is why he's so angry,
because every time he sends out a tweet, I'm just like,
I've gotten to know what he's going on about half the time. It's.
Super irritating. I guess I wouldn't.
I don't, for me, it's not, I don't care for me. It's, it's,
he's kind of taken this. He's kind of taken a,
it kind of insults my wife a lot. He's, he's, he's kind of a,
he's floated this idea that a lot of morons on the internet have
adopted this idea that Oasis would be getting back together,
but my wife won't let me,
so there's this fear that I'm at the kitchen table saying, Oh, please,
can I get part with Oasis? No, no. And I'm like,
please, please, please, please. No, uh, but the thing is because like,
most of the people who surf the internet are morons,
unfortunately present complete absolutely the course on,
fortunately that's now become that, like this thing, you know what I mean?
And my, my wife gets a lot of abuse,
which is not fair because she's gone nothing to do with it at all.
And he threatens my kids and all that kind of thing. And it's all,
it all gets a bit stupid. But, um, I w I,
I would say grow up one day, but he's 48 now. So it's.
So you had a little time left probably to, to grow.
I might do it in his fifties. Maybe.
It shouldn't be said he's not here to defend himself tonight. Yeah.
Uh, no, but she'd be watching this now. Furiously tweeting.
How, but how, as a father of three,
how do you with that cool, uh,
attitude deal with the tantrum because all kids have tantrums.
Yeah. Well, I would just say, well,
when my kids have tantrums, I find them hilarious,
laugh. You know,
when they're kind of like trying to hit you like a seven year old trying to hit
you, and you're just like weighed in on the best way. Well,
they say the best way to, um, you know, not the children's just to ignore them,
you know, but I mean, I, I do cause I'm not on social media, but, um,
it's difficult sometimes. You know what I mean? And it, I,
it has caused a lot of, uh, not upset,
but there's a lot of,
there's been a lot of things that have been said that are just like,
you're not going to be able to take that back. Do you know what I mean?
And I was born with one fatal flaw in my character, which is,
I will not forgive people. I can't do it. Or there's something in me that just,
I haven't got any forgiveness at all. Once the lines.
Will be no more.
I'm very stubborn. And what's the line has been crossed. I'm afraid. I can't,
I can't allow myself to, uh, to go back, but I guess if kid has a tantrum.
You can forgive him.
My children, I don't speak to my children.
How will you make sure that your kids stay friends,
but then the same thing won't happen again, the sentence of the fathers
hour.
My children's life and atmosphere at home was vastly different from the one that
I grew up in Oz was a very dysfunctional family.
Uh, when you think about it now and never really nobody ever really got on.
Um, and cause you know,
we grew up in the seventies and there was poverty and unemployment, blah, blah,
and all that. Um,
well my children's home life is very different.
I've got two loving parents and you know, they love the stepsister and um,
it's just, it's, it's,
it's a different atmosphere and you are a product of your environment, you know?
And if, if, if you're growing up in a house full of arguments,
you will eventually become like we became, you know,
and if you grow up in a loving environment, you know,
the people love and respect each other.
You will eventually grow up to be like that. You know what I mean? And, and,
and then as a parent, you cross your fingers and hope for the best.
Yeah.
[inaudible] I mean, you're both family, people,
family with big families.
Can it sometimes be too much. I mean, the Johnson's are quite many.
There are too many, many would say. Um,
I think it's hard for people who marry into the family and
one of my sisters in law, sisters in law. Oh,
I love them all dearly though. They're all incredible women. Um,
I was like saying, are you you guys coming to this? Or you know,
the football or blah.
And then I got this text back from my brother Leo's wife saying, no,
this it's a J F w. And I said, what's that? And she said,
Oh, don't, you know, it's a Johnson free weekend. And.
All the in-laws have this.
Concept of a Johnson free weekend where they're given a free pass and they
didn't have to come to some Sunday lunch or, you know,
tribal clam gathering. Well, I mean.
Family politics can be exhausting.
I don't know. Has Liam got kids? Yes. Many. How many
officially.
[Inaudible].
So you, your kids are a bit younger possibly, right? Yeah.
But aren't there occasions when you will have to be together
for weddings. And then how does that work? No,
nobody, uh.
As yet to get married yet. So the,
the situation has never arisen, but of course,
of course. And it's going to be very interesting.
Because that generation, they don't see each other.
Either. Uh, they do. Yeah. My daughter is 20. Uh, we'll see.
Uh, and as has gone to the same school as some of Liam's kids.
When, when do you work apart from touring? What do you write? I write music.
Every day.
I never really switched off from music it's because I don't have any hobbies.
I don't mind my,
my hobby growing up was playing the guitar and I've been lucky
enough to now it's a profession, you know, I don't, I don't drive.
So I've not got a fleet of cars.
I could just go and take drive around Europe or anything. You know what I mean?
I don't drive or you don't have a license to drive.
I've never had a driving lesson. It's never interested me ever. Um,
and so I, did you buy a lots of cars? I did.
[Inaudible].
It's kind of a double thing. You know what I mean? I bought, I had, uh, I had,
um, when we first got paid properly, uh,
I always wanted a Jaguar Mark two. And, uh, I found this company that,
that found old cars and put modern engines in them and all that.
And I went to see this place.
It took me three hours to get there in a car and they were going to,
they found this thing and it was the year I was born in 1967 and they say,
we'll take three years to build. And I was like, great.
I'll easily have passed my test in three years. And three years later,
I was in my house in St. John's wood. And then
Laurie pulled up the car on the back of it in the street. And of course.
God's amazing.
Get me. One of those cars wanted a guy walked in with a clipboard.
So there's Mr. Gallagher there. I was like, hi,
this is your car. And I'd forgotten that I'd bought and paid for.
It. I'm still going. I'm still.
Going to it's. Isn't a garbage somewhere.
And I think it's got like 12 miles on the clock. So I'm going to kind of leave.
It good news for your kids.
Well, I'm going to leave it for my kids to fight over.
No, it's fantastic to have you on the show. Thank you so much.
Hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.